es el primer mitin político en el que
participa donald trump desde el
allanamiento de su vivienda en florida
por lo que fue el primer tema que abordó
el exmandatario
el fbi y el departamento de justicia se
han convertido en muchos viciosos
controlados por sinvergüenzas de
izquierda radical abogados y medios de
comunicación que les dicen qué hacer y
cuándo hacerlo
el discurso se desarrolló en plena
campaña electoral por las elecciones de
medio término pensilvania es un estado
clave el jueves joe biden también hizo
campaña allí con una locución dirigida a
su predecesor y sus seguidores donald
trump le respondió
él es un enemigo del estado quieren
saber la verdad el enemigo del estado es
él y el grupo que lo controla el magnate
neoyorquino también se refirió a la
invasión rusia o ucrania y dijo que
vladimir putin nunca lo habría hecho con
él en el poder sus simpatizantes quienes
se identifican con el lema hacer eeuu
grande otra vez se hicieron presentes
desde horas tempranas en el sitio para
ver a quienes ellos catalogan como su
presidente
estoy muy entusiasmada con esto
considerando que aparentemente soy una
persona extremadamente maga lo que sólo
significa que eres patriota y amas a tu
país así que soy una miembro orgullosa y
extremadamente madre me paga el panorama
electoral en pensilvania ha dado un
vuelco en los últimos años zonas que
alguna vez fueron bastiones demócratas
hoy ofrecen su respaldo a donald trump